Wow, this
thing is nice.
MAN: This is
the cat's meow.
This is like one
of the holy grails
of American coins.
I'll do $95,
and that's it.
No, I don't
think so.
I think I'm going
to take it home.
This is
what a muscle
car is supposed
to look like.
This is the
real thing.
Not a clone, huh?
SELLER: The
real deal.
This is it.
Only 1175 made total.
It was originally
a Ford, as
all Shelby's were.
There was
right around 100
modifications
that Shelby
did to a Ford Mustang
to make the GT350.
This is one of the
quintessential cool
cars of the
1960s, and I would
love to have it.
So much are
you looking
to get out of it?
SELLER: My asking on
the car is $125,000.
I've done my
homework on this car.
I feel it's a fair
price what I'm
asking for the car.
I rarely do
this, but I'm not
going to negotiate.
I will give
you $100,000.
All right, so
that's the max
you're going to go?
- Not one dime more.
[sighs]
You got a deal.
Sweet.
Let's go do
some paperwork,
and um, we
can figure out
if my dad's
going to yell
at me for driving
for a week.
[chuckles]
My name's
Uncle Phil.
OK, Uncle Phil.
I have a 1932
Lincoln convertible.
A V12.
Um, yeah,
that's a cool car.
Yeah, it is, yeah.
This is a
classic car, Rick.
RICK: The '30s
was the golden age
of cars.
It was when
cars really
began to have style.
It's crazy that
Lincoln made
this bad ass ride
at the height
of the Great
Depression.
But think about
it, since there was
fewer buyers
for luxury cars
back then,
automakers had
to go all out
to compete
for their business.
In perfect
condition,
this could sell as
high as $170,000
at auction.
RICK: But
this is not in
perfect condition.
So buying this is
a little scary.
And how much do
you want for it?
- I want $100,000.
- OK.
I'll give you
$85,000 for it.
No.
I'll do $95,000,
and that's it.
I'll tell you what.
I know you have
a lot of gold,
and I'd like to
trade it for gold.
Legally, I can't
swap the gold
for the car.
But once I
give him cash,
he can turn
right around,
and buy the
gold off me.
We could do gold.
Will you
take $95,000?
OK.
RICK: All right.
RICK: Deal.
Here we
go, one more.
RICHARD: One
more time.
RICK: I deal in gold
here all the time.
Coins like
Krugerrands
and $20 gold
pieces, I'm
always stocked up.
- Here you go.
OK.
Thanks again.
Thanks a lot.
I appreciate
the business.
I can't believe
I just spent
$95,000 on a car.
I'm psyched, but
I've got to admit,
I'm a little nervous.
Got a 1922
proof high-relief
matt finished coin.
Where did
you get this?
SELLER 2: I won it
at a poker game.
RICK: Whoa.
The 1922 high-relief
piece dollar
is one of the
rarest coins
in American history.
But the more
demand for a coin,
the more it's faked.
I definitely
want this thing,
but I have to make
absolutely sure this
is the real deal.
So I called up Dave
to check everything
out for me.
- This is it.
Oh.
[laughing]
RICK: Now, what
exactly is the story
with this coin?
This was the coin the
government minted,
but no one knew
they minted it for
like 15 or 20 years.
DAVE: That's correct.
Now, a
high-relief design
was sort of a
triumph of art,
and a failure
of technology
because although
they were beautiful,
they couldn't
strike them
with enough pressure
to get a lot of them
out.
So I assume your
main concern
is, is it real?
- Yeah.
RICK: OK.
Definitely.
[chuckles]
DAVE: The coin
is perfectly
legitimate.
So the big thing
is what's it worth?
I think
this coin is
worth something
north of 50
but less than 100.
OK.
Thanks man.
DAVE: Super rare.
No problem.
OK.
DAVE: Thank you.
RICK: I'll give
you $65,000.
What about $90,000?
I think
$90,000 is fair
$75,000 is fair.
Meet in the
middle at $80,000,
and you've
got a deal.
It's a deal.
SELLER 2: All right.
OK.
I made $80,000
on the coin.
Super excited
about it.
Definitely going to
keep playing poker.
Hopefully, I
get another coin
like this sometime.